there is not an episode that I don't cry
and really cry it's not even just like
oh that's cute
this is like it's so emotional because
it's it's raw Courtney Cox is not
exaggerating she's executive producing a
new Facebook watch series called nine
months with Courtney Cox which gives an
intimate look inside the lives of people
across the nation all on their journeys
to have a baby
been trying for nine years I'm sure it's
a story about ten different couples that
are going on that you know taking us
through the journey of their pregnancy
and you know you deal with everything
from cancer to alcoholism whether you
can keep the baby whether you should
keep the baby whether you wanted to get
pregnant it's really what's happening
and yes I cried a lot the actress even
makes this candid admission I had a
bunch of miscarriages but I was really
lucky to have my little girl Coco who I
had through IVF did the series sort of
reignite some of those feelings or
reasons why you wanted to open up I know
you're supposed to be private I just
don't think like that I'm not I just
kind of say what's happening in my life
yes you probably not always served me
well but it's just who I am so if I can
share any light or give wisdom to
somebody or hope that of course I would
share anything I can and I think that's
important how thankful are you that you
are a mom and that your journey which
was a struggle ended up in Coco I'm
extremely thankful I feel very blessed
to have Coco I love watching and
experiencing with all these different
couples and single people and all just
everybody that we're following I just I
get to live vicariously through them do
you have advice for people after seeing
all these stories for families and women
and single people going through the
struggle of bringing life into this
world this is my motto in life I just
feel like just don't give up I'll always
keep trying I just believe that if if
your perseverance just keep going and
don't take no it's just maybe not yet
while promoting her new Facebook watch
series Courtney also opened up about a
recent experience that made headlines
when she boarded a plane with her pal
Jennifer Aniston and they were forced to
make an emergency landing yeah we were
just on a plane that was hit a pothole
and the tire I guess blew up blew off
blew up disintegrated cuz all I know all
I know is that it was missing the back
right tire but honestly we're very lucky
landing with one tire missing is
not as big a deal as it may sound when
you're on the plane okay so you're okay
everybody okay you still went and
enjoyed your weekend oh yeah